beyonce and jay-z were
among the guests who got in private
planes that is a very very very special
request granted only for the top top top
a-listers
george and amal clooney one year
requested a private bar so that they
could have a drink away from the rest of
the ayla celebrities
and they were given that that private
space
amal also got her own green room within
the museum please don't stop the music
music music rihanna her performance was
so memorable her fee i was told by a
very knowledgeable source was around a
million dollars
you could be a billionaire you are not
going to be able to buy your way into
the met gala but ultimately anna wintour
is deciding who is going to go yeah
that's right the vogue editor has been
in charge of fashion's biggest night
since 1999. so how do you land a ticket
well designers pay for tables a minimum
of 275 000 each and then anna handpicks
who gets to sit where the seating plan
at the met gala it is like a cia
operation so much thought goes into
where every single person is sitting and
also what that person is going to be
looking at from their seat when they're
sitting down and accommodations are made
for celebrities whenever possible
jennifer lopez for instance when she
attended the gala when she was dating
marc anthony but nobody knew
so they attended the event separately
but the planners knew and they sat them
back to back so that they could be
together but no one would speculate over
what was going on with them
all of these med gala secrets and more
are included in anna the biography now
tuesday from fashion writer turned
author amy odell she got anna's blessing
to write the book and interviewed more
than 250 people that list included
everyone from tom ford to serena
williams to tory burch
one of the biggest criticisms of the met
gala in the fashion world particularly
is that it's become halloween
that it's become a costume party tom
ford said he misses the old days of the
met gala when
you didn't have to
dress like a chandelier you didn't have
to dress like a hamburger both of which
were worn by katy perry anna wintour
however she loves the over-the-top look
in fact when lady gaga turned the red
carpet into a catwalk quick change in
2019 anna stopped in her tracks to watch
and as for this you have no style or
sense of fashion amy says anna wasn't
bothered by the blockbuster film the
devil wears prada she really didn't care
and she actually encouraged designers to
advise on the film famously starring
meryl streep she told them go ahead
take a chance
at a screening for the devil wears prada
in new york to which anna attended
wearing prada because she does have a
cheeky sense of humor the director of
the film told me that he sat right
behind anna and her daughter b and after
the film and the credits were rolling he
heard b lean over and say to anna mom
they really got you that's all
you